castles are a universal fantasy but in
Irish castle hotel where you can try
medieval sports like falconry and then
sleep in rooms more plush and modern
than when the Guinness family owned them
yes that Guinness now that's what we
call a fantasy getaway
set on 350 acres of woodland forest in
western Ireland Ashford Castle has
evolved over its almost 800 years
everything is a little undulating so
it's it's a discovery for me I think it
takes one a month to get used to the
place you know there are so many
alleyways and some so many nooks and
crannies the 82 room hotel just
underwent some 26 million in gut
renovations each room is unique
bespoke they all have their different
colors and there's no two rooms the same
it's so much easier to have to clean the
rooms because everything is done you
when everything's painted there's a new
cinema and a billiards room with a peat
fireplace the redone Georgia v
restaurant is as fantastic as when first
built for the Kings visit in 1906 dinner
is a great part of everyday for us I
just love this room I love what we do
here and the food we produce here
unlike most hotels staff here keep on
for decades there's a lot of humor
involved in this a lot of perkiness we
have Patti the porter who's been here
for so many years
if you mentioned Patti the porter
anywhere people understand and know that
it's a spur Castle traditions thrive
here proper aristocratic activities like
archery are throw back there's also
horseback riding and fly fishing on
Lough Corrib there are even real Fox
hunts it's one of the last remaining
actual hunts that you can experience
anywhere like the world but I came for
the falconry
meet Beckett he's a year and a half old
Harris Hawk and he's my hunting partner
for the day
unlike peregrine falcons which don't
like strangers Harris Hawks are the
world's only social birds of prey so
this is the falconry glove and it goes
on your left arm to hold back it you're
gonna make a fist so he's gonna take a
step that's it today we're going to be
part of the pack we're going to be the
motivation to hunt you can't train a
bird of prey like a hunting dog
they won't fetch a kill but they will
trade it for a chicken foot Hey nice
flight Beckett you can say to this bird
if you give me the big pheasant or that
crow that's kicking and screaming I'll
give you something easier to eat careful
though feed them too much and they'll
stop cooperating the term fed up that
comes from falconry as does being under
the thumb and hoodwinked and that's the
magic of asteroid
heritage links comfortably to modern-day
history keeps on something keeps drawing
you back
I don't what it is I loved place I would
just leave unless they throw me out